[Music]
Rob and I played out last two last night
for a little bit I've also played a
little bit about lists and Kelly played
out west - first time I played it was a
demo at PAX East 2015 and that was kind
of like a grab bag of what was going on
the game there's like these poltergeist
sections in a school there's these more
like weird kind of Texas Chainsaw
Massacre farm rural residents Evan vibes
and then it would thing that the demo
excited me was the fact that it was
actually kind of a cool uh like
smorgasbord of this stuff like that but
it's felt like it was doing well like
pacing well but I played more last night
and I think I had more positive reaction
than you did I don't I haven't played
enough to really have a strong opinion
of it to uh preface this Scott
Butterworth who has since left GameSpot
and he will be missed
editor he it was his last review he gave
it a 7 out of 10 and I can get through
his thoughts as well like a few of them
I don't want to you go you can go read
that right now it's welleran and stuff
and he can convey that better with that
than I can just with bullet point list
but from our I want to also give our
initial impressions but yeah Scott was
saying it it's scary the tonally and in
terms of atmosphere it nails it sound
design he says it's one of the better
well design games in horror but it kinda
can get repetitive and as opposed to the
first game which took place in this
little more open Asylum is kind of gated
at certain points by certain items or
characters that you need to talk to this
games a little more linear and sometimes
begin to this chase sequences which the
first one kind of popularized it also
popularized first person horror but this
one when you're running you still have
that mechanic to hold like l1 or lb and
look behind you which can kind of
heighten the intensity god that's yes so
scary yeah um but sometimes it's too
specific where you need to run to I can
get frustrating if you don't really know
what they want you to do to avoid an
enemy
I found that last night almost like one
of the first enemies I encountered I was
like what do they want me to do is right
here ya know this is that I was about to
mention this sequence is yeah this I did
not like this this bish and I
the I'd like died several times I was
playing because I couldn't figure out
it's like where it wanted me to go
that's super fun yeah and it wasn't it
was like almost very specific thing that
I had to do at least maybe we found but
I mean it's frustrating because it's not
cheating Mary yeah it stops being scary
after the second time when you're like
now I just need to figure out the right
game a fide thing and then it's like you
have to end up kind of crawling under
this hole and it's hard to see which
that itself isn't bad but it's like I
don't know it's not clear how quickly
you have to run to escape her and I
totally felt like she was going to grab
me from the hole like that didn't happen
it was just it was it was not smooth
mm-hmm yeah like I I'm thinking of just
the last Resident Evil right where if
they catch you generally you can you
know you're still in it
well you also back around and then and
then you keep running I mean to be in
defense of ls2 resonable you had a
plethora of weapons to use against
enemies yeah I love less you mean when
they actually grabbed you which yeah you
can still block in this game you're much
more defenseless yeah I like that first
part like after I finally got through it
just left me with a yep yeah all that
the fifth time she stabbed you in the
genitals kind of wears off that's what I
said to you uh yeah I felt like it was
excessive weight no hold on know what
Gina lies yeah that's what you said you
said after the fourth time they penalize
me for being caught and then you gave me
this stare and there's a wink wink
got him back to outlast honestly I
looked it was just I was like just
getting over it but fifth time I'm
watching that area get ripped in half
replaced by a scythe yeah like I I don't
know it's it's a little much for him but
but I I can't say anything I mean I want
to keep playing cuz you know uh I feel
like Mike you have a pretty good taste
in game so I mean I believe you when it
when you say that it gets better I mean
it that that area was just such a trial
and error that I did not enjoy yeah
again trying to find one specific area
opposed to like now as mentioned view
light in that same area that you know
there are all these doors that you are
I'm going up to and they could be locked
some of them just don't even have any
interactive prompt yeah it it that
frustrated me where I in that moment I'm
unsure of whether or not this is even
something I can interact with like I
it's hard to like it's hard experiment
in that one moment but again baby your
sound design yeah the crunchy squishy
noise I'm oh really got it
we're walking over them gross um but
yeah it actually in terms of so I do
have a question from a Nicki Jay on
Twitter saying our jump scares and chase
sequences enough to keep the horror
genre alive both are great but what can
make the genre better in relation to
this game definitely jump scares there's
one a kind of people around the game
SWAT offices now I startle easily but
there was one here that genuinely got me
um I don't know if you guys got far
enough but it was very sudden but uh the
chase sequences I found I haven't I got
two one like scripted one but none of
you ever get discovered you can run to
the next checkpoint or wherever you're
going
but I actually like what this game is
doing with this occult stuff and the
farther and you get the more you realize
it's actually not just this grab bag of
these kind of cultist tropes it's
actually there's a story up here there's
two there there is more to it than I
initially realized and I do like the
angle of shooting these things with you
know you use the camera to review
footage and he can actually present kind
of uh his insight into what's going on
in addition to yours but uh yeah I like
I like the viewing it through the camera
I got like Blair Witch vibes from the
occult stuff cuz it's like at first um I
thought you know like I get really weary
of a cult because it's like oh it can so
easily go into that like weird trophy
territory but the further you get it is
more interesting you know god right room
if you ask me I the gore stuff I
actually in mind I okay so the the it
Ron made resna before you go to this
remote village this is an Arizona
resident for kind of the Las Plagas and
the ganado sand the
yeah yeah but this is you know they're
not as far as I'm into the game and I'm
not that that far they're not zombies
but uh yeah so Scott was saying like the
patient goes but yeah you can hide like
amnesia kind of defenceless she sucks
yeah gonna guess oh I hate how lanky she
is that gets that gets me yep and you
know the more you actually play through
the more they I think the pacing is
really good if you don't get you can
occasionally get caught up on these
certain chases and that does suck
because in the first game you felt more
like you had options to escape robbed
like you were mentioning kind of like
Resident Evil but this one it's much
more linear than the first game the
first one is that asylum and that you'd
be like and go by the base maybe like I
don't want to go down that basement
right now that sounds awful I can hear
that person down there but this stuff
about this Jessica girl you start having
these you hear your character's insight
as to what actually happened and then it
starts tying kind of you and a few other
characters together it actually these
flashbacks are pretty good that
flashback is a weird term and if you
play the game you'll see why so these
aren't exactly flashbacks but it ties
into the main story really well I think
so far and I want to play more I think
Scott said he beat it in about 12 hours
so it's decently lengthy game for this
kind of game so I could see where that
might wear thin but yeah I'm curious to
see where it goes yeah I feel like I it
would take me a long time to get through
a 12-hour game like this just because I
would need to take breaks right like
fatigued right so I was feeling last
night but I'm sure once I get some speed
into it then I can play for longer yeah
absolutely we're doing a three at like
sitting down for three hours and playing
after that I was exhausted yeah um yeah
anyway I mean like I don't want to talk
too much about this without spoiling it
but in terms of the first game so far
I'm actually kind of underwhelmed
because I think the first game what I
liked about it being one of the games
that popularized first person horror I
think you know what there was at 2013 I
think that did a great job of putting me
in this asylum the setting which
everybody's done silent this point I'm
glad they moved away from it but I like
that like I said that you have multiple
avenues to escape it you can actually
think through like Scott mentioned in
the review you can kind of think through
going to get this battery or this key
you need while this guy chases you but
you can maybe
back under that bed before that happens
but this one our last two feels too
scripted so far to me and I realize
that's kind of a lure this this game
maybe but I think they're telling the
story well I just think it's kind of uh
no it's not rolling me along everyone's
so lanky yeah six Slenderman I know he
is like the Slenderman
yeah the Slenderman but anyway yeah you
can go read the full review again my
Scott Potter Werth who has left GameSpot
he will be missed but that is his last
review can go read that you give it a 7
out of 10 it's out as of yesterday on
Xbox one ps4 PC didn't go check it out
so far I recommend it I think it's good
and I want to finish it among all the
other releases but let us know what you
think in the comments below if you liked
the first outlast you plan on checking
this one out I don't know like how do
you think it compares to a resonable 7
what it does differently what it does
better what it does worse and we'll look
forward to your thoughts
[Music]